foreign
Nissan have announced a long plan
overhaul of their more than 20 year old
Alliance
we are now ready to move our partnership
obviously to a new era
the partnership withstood the ousting of
a leader
a global pandemic and growing pains
the CEOs of both companies spoke to the
Wall Street Journal about their
restructured Alliance and what it means
for investors and the global industry
importance is how we can transform right
under this difficult circumstances that
we are facing today so we're trying to
create a company that is much more agile
more oriented to Innovation because the
technology is evolutionary but first how
did we get here
the partnership dates to 1999 when
Renaud took a more than one-third stake
in Nissan which was struggling they were
in this kind of marriage where they had
to get the agreement of the other if
they wanted to cooperate at the height
of the alliance they were joined by
Mitsubishi Motors and had a combined
sales of more than 10 million Vehicles a
year
but beneath the surface Nissan saw the
partnership as uneven with Renault
holding a controlling stake in the
Japanese car maker on the other hand
Renault felt it wasn't getting enough
for its large stake there was also a
clash of corporate cultures
for years industry veteran Carlos scone
headed both companies and was able to
smooth out differences with his forceful
personality
but when gome was arrested in Japan over
Financial charges in 2018 tensions
between Renault and Nissan Spilled Out
into the open
he denies the charges and eventually
fled the country when you took callers
going out of the equation there was no
real good way for these companies to
cooperate and you realize actually what
we're going have been doing for so many
years was refereeing some kind of cat
fights
then came further challenges covet
Supply chains and we have a geopolitical
situation make the material cost and
hike and the cost is going to the sky
local situation Renault had to sell its
majority stakes in Russia's biggest
automaker after the Ukraine war broke
out it capped off more than two years of
losses two years and a half ago we were
really in a bad shape you know we lost
like 8 billion euros in a semester so I
was like wow so we are we know 600
billion and that's a red amid the crisis
where no CEO thought there was also an
opportunity for the French car maker to
reinvent itself and all the things we're
doing are first to make sure that there
are no you know on the on the next Grand
Prix will be better positioned because
it will be different rules different
different technical setup Etc but it's
never done against you know the alliance
or against Nissan in fact they can take
advantage of some of our experience I
think also and vice versa it became
clear to both sides they'd be better off
operating more independently of each
other we had many things in the past
right but we are not doing this
like for sake of the debalancing or you
know Nissan big tree Renault big tree on
historical items I think we have to
sometimes go back to the original Spirit
which was a very very pragmatic
collaboration that's what we've tried
we've tried to do Under the new
agreement Renault will reduce its stake
in Nissan from 43 to 15 percent Nissan
will also invest in renault's electric
vehicle and software business they can
keep cooperating on certain things if
they want and if both parties see the
benefit or they can go and seek other
partners if they think they can get a
better deal my focus is of course is
creating the uniqueness of Renault that
needs to be different from Nissan they
have to have a different strategy from
us it's good so we cannot really do the
business in extension from the past way
for the future because the circumstance
is still very different this is why we
made this announcement to go into the
next daylr and what kind of the uh
governance that we should have in
Department ship or structure the deal
comes as both companies look to new
types of Partnerships and batteries EV
technology and software
the chipmaker Qualcomm has already said
it would take a stake in renault's new
EV business on pair Don pair is a very
reasonable investment with a very strong
return on the capital locations for
Nissan or for any investor with very
good products that people are willing to
you know pay for this is a chance that
many other newcomers coming from the
outside don't have Renault Nissan have
said their Alliance will continue and
announce joint projects in markets such
as Argentina Mexico and India we are
setting up the new stage for the
alliance how to collaborate how to work
and if there's opportunity why not but
several issues remain open Nissan did
not say how much it would invest in
renault's EV company also under
negotiation is the intellectual property
that goes into that Renault Venture
which is owned by Nissan this is also
why it's difficult for investors because
there are still some negotiations to
take place this isn't like the the
complete end of the story